muss an der stelle erst mal meine
verwunderung zum ausdruck bringen
erstmal guten abend übrigens in die
runde war und deshalb komme aus
rheinland-pfalz lehrergewerkschaft tätig
und es ist eben nicht so dass die
schulen bis mitte februar zu bleiben wir
starten am ersten februar mit wechsel
unterricht und die schulen in
rheinland-pfalz und ich spreche da
bestimmt auch für alle anderen und viele
bundesländer sind überhaupt nicht
hinreichend was den gesundheitsschutz
angeht vorbereitung das nach zehn
monaten pandemie stellt das einen das
davor große fragen wir brauchen
eigentlich endlich ein masterplan für
deutschland für die schule in
deutschland und zwar heißt das was sind
die mindest dann das eines klassenraumes
an digitalisierung und nicht jedes
bundesland jeder schulträger geht
alleine auf die reise dass dies einfach
nur peinlich was hier veranstaltet wird
wir brauchen eine schnur ja und noch ein
punkt noch dieses diene dieser
digital.com sie gerade auf einen an eine
sache die mir ganz wichtig ist ich
verstehe es nicht ich habe im märz april
im bildungsausschuss in rheinland pfalz
im landtag habe ich gesagt schafften sie
die konzepte ab für die schuhträger die
die schreiben müssen und für die schulen
deshalb mehrere wochen gedauert bis die
frau wich dass man oben weitergegeben
hat und erst mal umgesetzt worden ist
als gab gehabt asiatin sihe wir müssen
endlich und zwar nachhaltig ein
masterplan für die digitalisierung der
schulen haben das geht ganz schnell ich
sehe ihre bemühungen aber wir brauchen
einfach taten
wenn wir immer nur überlegen was können
wir verbessern es muss was passieren